good morning Hank it's Tuesday two days
we didn't come to in three very special
parts business exciting announcements
and mosquito-borne illnesses one
business so Hank in last week's video
asked people we should turn on pre-roll
advertisements for vlogbrothers and then
if so what we should do with that
revenue tens of thousands of people
respond and taken they voted
overwhelmingly that we should turn on
pre-rolls and that we should split the
income between the foundation to
decrease worldsuck and a fund that will
help out educational video projects so
that's what we're gonna do and
nerdfighters we will keep you up to date
on how that money is spent by the way
Hank did you notice that I have a tan
I've been experimenting a little bit
without side although I can't in good
faith recommend it also I've got some
puffs because I'm in control of my own
haircut schedule for the first time in
six months people in Hollywood have lots
of opinions about how often you should
get a haircut part two exciting
announcement so I am going to East
Africa with Bill Gates I'm very excited
about this trip not only because I get
to hang out with Bill Gates but also
because I get to meet a lot of people
who are doing important work in health
and agriculture and hopefully I'm gonna
learn a lot and make a bunch of videos
but that brings me to part three
mosquito-borne illnesses so I keeps
changing it's like a 2007 blog brothers
video so make ask you know some of my
anxiety problems Center on physical
health and when my doctor was giving me
the vaccines to get ready for this trip
he said you should read the CDC webpages
about the places that you'll be visiting
and that was a terrible idea because
there's website took like malaria
mosquitos bite mostly at night time long
yellow fever mosquitos bike primarily
during the day and West Nile mosquitoes
bite at dawn and dusk and reading that
stuff made me think I am going to a
place where disease ridden mosquitoes
bite in shifts so I called my doctor and
I was like this doesn't seem safe at all
and he said you should read the Indiana
State Department of Health webpage so I
did and in addition to having
information about the West Nile virus
which I knew to be worried about there
was a warning about the arbovirus which
I've never even heard of and one about
the chicken olia virus which I don't
even know how to pronounce Hank I don't
want to be killed by something that I
can't pronounce I think my doctor
thought I would emerge from that
experience less anxious but but quite
the opposite anyway all of this is just
to say that I have recently become I
think the only person in the history of
the world to read the entire Indiana
State Department of Health website no
wait I also have another point
we have excellent healthcare facilities
and information here in the United
States we've got a great infrastructure
the power very rarely goes off in health
clinics and all that stuff helps us to
deal with mosquito-borne illnesses and
other communicable diseases relatively
effectively and I'm going to East Africa
a night to see how they've dramatically
improved healthcare and reduced infant
mortality in the last 20 years and also
to see how much work there still is to
be done and where we can help I'm gonna
make a bunch of videos but they probably
won't be uploaded during my trip so in
the meantime I'm going to make a video
about behind the beautiful forevers the
nerdfighter book club pick for summer if
you haven't read it now at the time
because it will make next week's video
more enjoyable and B it's excellent it
won the Pulitzer Prize for God's sakes
but anyway yeah I will schedule that
video to upload next Tuesday so that I
don't get punished speaking of
punishments Hank you owe us one
nerdfighters I need punishment
suggestions for Hank in the comments
Hank dftba I will see you on Friday